this morning we are hearing from Tesla
Auto Workers who were worried about
their safety on the job we first told
you about this yesterday about a new
report by the advocacy group WorkSafe it
claims that Tesla's rapid growth clamp
comes rather at the expense of assembly
line workers at its factory in Fremont
California that's near San Francisco the
group has released Tesla safety data to
back up its claims Carter Evans visited
the factory he would he's with us now
from Santa Monica Carter good morning
good morning the company says safety is
a top priority and always has been but
until now Tesla has repeatedly declined
to release its factory safety records
from years past this new report does
exactly that the vehicle itself is an
amazing you know accomplishment it's how
they get it built and what we have to go
through to make that happen for them
these for Tesla auto workers say the
assembly line and what's supposed to be
the factory of the future is behind the
times when it comes to safety what is
the chief complaint here injuries
injuries are the number one problem
there
you know burned out everybody in our
areas burned out we're trying to run as
high as we can Tesla body repair
technician John Gillespie wants workers
here to unionize on the advice of the
United Auto Workers Union he legally
obtained three years of internal injury
reports from the company an independent
analysis of those numbers found that in
2015 Tesla's injury rate was 31% higher
than the industry average the rate of
serious injuries that resulted in days
away from work or restricted duty was
double I don't think it's reflective of
what where we are currently
Tesla human resources director Josh
hedges says safety improvements have
already been made
he points to injury numbers from the
first quarter of this year which Tesla
says are now 32 percent below the
industry average what do you make of
these complaints and allegations that
are out there
it's coming from a small number that's
not really reflective of the environment
that you see here to prove it Tesla
provided three managers who explained
how the company brought in
ergonomics experts and added an extra
shift putting in place the three shifts
things that are having to shift some
just 12-hour shifts I made a huge
difference in people's work-life balance
they're not extreme their bodies every
day all day but these workers say that
may not be enough with what's coming
down the line the model 3 is being
billed as an affordable electric car for
the masses but making it means a massive
production increase for Tesla workers
you guys helped produce about 84,000
cars last year this company is going to
be expected to produce half a million of
them next year how are you going to do
this that's a good question they're in
tremendous pressure to build when that
happens you can't ignore other important
issues they're concerned they're going
to pay the price for this ramp up in
production Tesla is about the safety of
our employees and we've built the line
with ergonomics involved so by no means
do production numbers come before the
safety of our employees now Tesla is not
disputing the injury rates reported in
the analysis the company is hoping
though that it's revamped assembly line
for the model 3 will reduce injury rates
even further and the company says its
goal is to reduce injuries on the line
to zero there you go all right Carter
thank you so much